the following is a conversation with
Daniel Kahneman winner of the Nobel
Prize in Economics for his integration
of economic science with a psychology of
human behavior judgment and
decision-making he's the author of the
popular book Thinking Fast and Slow that
summarizes in an accessible way his
research of several decades often in
collaboration with Amos Tversky a
cognitive biases prospect theory and
happiness the central thesis of this
work is the dichotomy between two modes
of thought what he calls system one is
fast instinctive and emotional system
two is slower more deliberative and more
logical the book delineates cognitive
biases associated with each of these two
types of thinking his study of the human
mind and his peculiar and fascinating
limitations are both instructive and
inspiring for those of us seeking to
engineer intelligent systems this is the
artificial intelligence podcast if you
enjoy it subscribe on YouTube give it
five stars an Apple podcast follow on
Spotify supported on patreon or simply
connect with me on Twitter Alex Friedman
spelled Fri D ma a.m. I recently started
doing ads at the end of the introduction
I'll do one or two minutes after
introducing the episode and never any
ads in the middle that can break the
flow of the conversation I hope that
works for you and doesn't hurt the
listening experience this show is
presented by cash app the number one
finance app in the App Store I
personally use cash app to send money to
friends but you can also use it to buy
sell and deposit Bitcoin in just seconds
cash app also has a new investing
feature you can buy fractions of a stock
say $1 worth no matter what the stock
price is brokerage services are provided
by cash app investing a subsidiary of
square and member si PC I'm excited to
be working with cash app to support one
of my favorite organizations called
first best known for their first
robotics and Lego competitions they
educate and inspire hundreds of
thousands of students in over 110
countries and have a perfect rating a
charity navigator which means that
donated money is used to maximum
effectiveness when you get cash app from
the App Store Google Play and use code
Lex podcast you'll get ten dollars in
cash up will also donate ten dollars to
the first which again is an organization
that I've personally seen inspire girls
and boys the dream of engineering a
better world and now here's my
conversation with Daniel Kahneman you
tell a story of an SS soldier early in
the war world war two in nazi-occupied
France and Paris where you grew up
he picked you up and hugged you and
showed you a picture of a boy maybe not
realizing that you were Jewish
not maybe certainly not so I told you
I'm from the Soviet Union that was
significantly impacted by the words well
and I'm Jewish as well what do you think
World War two taught us about human
psychology broadly well I think the the
only big surprise is the extermination
policy genocide by the German people
that's when you look back on it and you
know I think that's a major surprise
it's a surprise because it's a surprise
that they could do it it's a surprise
that they that enough people willingly
participated in that this is this is a
surprise
now it's no longer a surprise but it's
changed many people's views I think
about about human beings certainly for
me the Ackman trial in a teaches you
something because it's very clear that
if it could happen in Germany it could
happen anywhere it's not that the
Germans were special this could happen
anyway so what do you think that is do
you think we're all capable of evil
we're all capable of cruelty I don't
think in those terms I think that what
is certainly possible
is you can dehumanize people so that
there you treat them
not as people anymore but as animals and
and the same way that you can slaughter
animals without feeling much of anything
it can the same and when you feel that
the I think the combination of
dehumanizing the other side and and
having uncontrolled power over other
people I think that doesn't bring out
our the most generous aspect of human
nature so that Nazi soldier you know he
he was a good man I mean you know and he
was perfectly capable of killing a lot
of people and I'm sure he did
but what what did the Jewish people mean
to Nazis so what the dismissal of Jewish
as well worthy of again this is
surprising that it was so extreme but
it's not one thing in human nature I
don't want to call it evil but the
distinction between the in-group and the
out-group that is very basic
so that's built in the the loyalty and
affection towards in-group and the
willingness to dehumanize the out-group
that's that is in human nature and
that's that's what I think probably
didn't need the Holocaust to teach us
that but the Holocaust is a very sharp
lesson of you know what can happen to
people and when the people can do so the
effect of the in-group and the out-group
you know that it's clear that those were
people you know you could you could
shoot them you could you know they were
not human they were not there was no
empathy or very very little empathy left
so occasionally you know they might have
been and and very quickly by the way the
empathy disappeared if there was
initially and the fact that everybody
around you was doing it
that that completely the group doing it
and everybody shooting Jews I think that
that makes it permissible now how much
you know whether it would it could
happen or in every culture or whether
the Germans were just particularly
efficient and and disciplined so they
could get away with it that is a
question it's an interesting question
are these artifacts of history or is it
human nature I think that's really human
nature you know you put some people in a
position of power relative to other
people and and then they become as human
become different but in general and war
outside of concentration camps in World
War two
it seems that war brings out darker
sides of human nature but also the
beautiful things about human nature well
no I mean but it what it brings out is
the loyalty among soldiers I mean it
brings out the bonding male bonding I
think is a very real thing that and that
happens and so and and there is a
student of thrill to friendship and
there is certainly a certain thrill to
friendship under risk and to shared risk
and so people have very profound
emotions up to the point where it gets
so traumatic that that little is left
but so let's talk about psychology a
little bit in your book Thinking Fast
and Slow you described two modes of
thoughts as the one the fast instinctive
an emotional one is system to the slower
deliberate logical one at the risk of
asking Darwin to discuss a theory of
evolution
can you describe distinguishing
characteristics for people who have not
read your book of the two systems well I
mean the mood
system is a bit misleading but it's at
the same time it's misleading it's also
very useful but what I call system one
it's easier to think of it as as a
family of activities and primarily the
way I describe it is there are different
ways for ideas to come to my mind and
some ideas come to mind automatically
and the example a standard example is
two plus two and then something happens
to you and and in other cases you've got
to do something you got to work in order
to produce the idea and my example I
always give the same pair of numbers is
27 times 14 I think you have to perform
some algorithm in your heads and yes and
and it takes time it's a very difference
nothing comes to mind except something
comes to mind which is the algorithm I
mean that you've got to perform and then
it's work and it engages short-term
memory and thing ages executive function
and it makes you incapable of doing
other things at the same time so the the
main characteristic of system 2 is that
there is mental effort involved and
there is a limited capacity for mental
effort where a system one is effortless
essentially that's the major distinction
so you talk about there you know it's
really convenient to talk about two
systems but you also mentioned just now
and in general that there's no distinct
two systems in the brain from a
neurobiological even from psychology
perspective but why does it seem to from
the experiments you've conducted there
does seem to be kind of emergent two
modes of thinking so at some point these
kinds of systems came into a brain
architecture
maybe ma'am will share it but the or do
you not think of it at all in those
terms that it's all on mush and these
two things just emerge you know
evolutionary theory saying about this is
cheap and easier so it's the way I think
about it is that it's very clear that
animals have a perceptual system and
that includes an ability to understand
the world at least to the extent that
they can predict they can't explain
anything but they can anticipate what's
going to happen and that's the key form
of understanding the world and my crude
idea is that we would I call system -
well system - grew out of this and you
know there is language and there is the
capacity of manipulating our ideas and
the capacity of imagining futures and of
imagining counterfactuals thing that
haven't happened and and to do
conditional thinking and there are
really a lot of abilities that without
language and without the the very large
brain that we have compared to others it
would be impossible now
system one is more like what the animals
are but system one also can talk I mean
it has language it understands language
indeed it speaks for us I mean you know
I'm not choosing every word you know as
a deliberate process the words I have
some idea and then the words come out
and that's automatic and effortless and
many of experiments you've done is to
show that listen system won't exist and
it does speak for us and we should be
careful about it's the voice it provides
well it's I mean you know we have to
trust it because it's the speed at which
it acts a system is usable if we if we
depend on one system to for survival we
wouldn't survive very long because it's
very slow yeah crossing the street
crossing a street I mean many things
depend on there being automatic one very
important aspect of system one is that
it's not instinct
you use the word instinct that it
contains skills that clearly have been
learned so that skilled behavior like
driving a car or speaking in fact
skilled behavior has to be learned and
so it doesn't you know you don't come
equipped with with driving you have to
learn how to drive and and you have to
go through a period where driving is not
automatic before it becomes automatic
so yeah you construct I mean this is
where you talk about heuristic and
biases you to make it automatic you
create a pattern and then system one
essentially matches a new experience
against a previously seen pattern and
when that match is not a good one that's
when the cognate all of them all the
mess happens but it's most of the time
it works and so it's pretty most of the
time the anticipation of what's going to
happen next is correct and and most of
the time the plan about what you have to
do is correct and so most of the time
everything works just fine what's
interesting actually is that in some
sense system one is much better at what
it does
and system tool is at what it does that
is there is that quality of effortlessly
solving enormous ly complicated problems
which clearly exists so that the chess
player a very good chess player all the
moves that come to their mind are strong
moves so all the selection of strong
moves happens unconsciously and
automatically and very very fast and and
all that is in system one so you a
system two verifies so along this line
of thinking really what we are our
machines that construct a pretty
effective system one you could think of
it that way so so we're now talking
about humans but if we think about
building artificial intelligence systems
robots do you think all the features in
bug
that you have highlighted in human
beings are useful for constructing AI
systems so both systems are useful for
perhaps while instilling in robots what
is happening these days is that actually
what is happening in deep learning is is
more like a system one product than like
a system to product I mean deep learning
mattress patterns and anticipate what's
going to happen so it's highly
predictive what's right what deep
learning doesn't have and you know many
people think that this is the critical
it it doesn't have the ability to reason
so it it does and there is no system to
bear but I think very importantly it
doesn't have any causality or any way to
represent meaning and to represent real
interaction so until that is solved the
you know what can be accomplished is
marvelous and very exciting but limited
that's actually really nice to think of
current advances in machine learning is
essentially system one advances so how
far can we get with just system one if
we think of learning and artificial
systems and we know it's very clear that
deep mind is already gone we're way
beyond what people thought was possible
I think I think the thing that has
impressed me most about the developments
in AI is the speed it's that things at
least in the context of deep learning
and maybe this is about to slow down but
things moved a lot faster than
anticipated the transition from solving
solving chess to solving go was I mean
that's the world rain how quickly it
went the move from alphago to alpha 0 is
sort of bewildering the speed at which
they accomplish that
now clearly there they're eight so there
are many problems that you can solve
that way but there's some problem
for which who needs something else
something like a reasoning where
reasoning and also you know that one of
the real mysteries psychologist there
Gary Marcus who is also a critic of AI I
mean he what he points out and I think
he has a point is that humans learn
quickly children don't need million
examples they need two or three examples
so clearly there is a fundamental
difference and what enables what enable
the machine to to learn quickly what you
have to build into the machine because
it's that you have to build some
expectations or something in the machine
to make it ready to learn quickly
that's that at the moment seems to be
unsolved I'm pretty sure that the mind
is working on it but yeah there if they
have solved it I haven't heard yet
they're trying to actually them an open
they are trying to start to get to use
neural networks to reason so assemble
knowledge of course causality is
temporal causality is out of reach to
most everybody you mentioned the
benefits of system one is essentially
that it's fast allows us to function in
the world now some skilled you know its
skill and it has a model of the world
you know in a sense I mean there was the
earlier phase of a I attempted to moral
reasoning and they were moderately
successful but you know reasoning by
itself doesn't get you much deep
learning has been much more successful
in terms of you know what they can do
but now it's an interesting question
whether its approaching its limits what
do you think I think absolutely so I
just talked to John laocoon he mentioned
you know I know him so he thinks that
the limits were
not going to hit the limits with you all
networks that ultimately this kind of
system on pattern matching will start to
start to look like system two with
without significant transformation of
the architecture so I'm more with the
but the majority of the people who think
that yes new all networks will hit a
limit in their capability he on the one
hand I have heard him tell the missus
obvious essentially that you know what
they have accomplished it's not a big
deal that they have just touched that
basically you know they can't do
unsupervised learning in in an effective
way and but you're telling me that he
thinks that the current within the
current architecture you can do
causality and reasoning so he's very
much a pragmatist in a sense that saying
that were very far away that they're
still yeah I think there's this idea
that he says is uh we can only see one
or two mountain peaks ahead and there
might be either a few more after or
thousands more after yeah so that kind
of idea right but nevertheless it
doesn't see a the final answer not
fundamentally looking like one that we
currently have
so neural networks being a huge part
that you know I mean that's very likely
because because pattern matching is so
much of what's going on and you can
think of neural networks as processing
information sequentially yeah I mean you
know there is there is an important
aspect to for example you get systems
that translate and they do a very good
job but they really don't know what
they're talking about and and and for
that I'm really quite surprised for that
you would need you would need an AI that
has sensation an AI that is in touch
with the world awareness and maybe even
something resembles consciousness kind
of ideas li awareness of you know
awareness of what's going on so
that the the words have meaning who can
get are in touch with some perception or
some action yeah so that's a big thing
for yarn and as well here first is
grounding to the physical space so so
that's what we're talking about the same
yeah so but so how you ground I mean the
grounding without grounding then you get
you get a machine that doesn't know what
it's talking about because it is talking
about the world ultimately the question
open question is what it means to ground
I mean we're very human centric in our
thinking but what does it mean for a
machine to understand what it means to
be in this world does it need to have a
body does he need to have a finiteness
like we humans have all of these
elements it's very nice to know I'm you
know I'm not sure about having a body
but having a perceptual system having a
body would be very helpful to me if if
you think about human mimicking human
ooh but having a perception that seems
to be central so that you can build you
can accumulate knowledge about the world
so if you can you can imagine a human
completely paralyzed and there's a lot
that the human brain could learn you
know with a paralyzed body so if we got
a machine that could do that it would be
a big deal and then the flip side of
that something you see in children and
something in machine learning world is
called active learning maybe it is is
being able to play with the world how
important for developing system owners
or system to do you think it is to play
with the world be able to interact with
me a lot a lot of what you learn as you
learn to anticipate the outcomes of your
actions I mean you can see that how
babies learn it you know with their
hands they are they learn you know to
connect you know the movement so their
hands with something that clearly is
something that happens
in the brain and and and the ability of
the brain to learn new patterns so you
know it's the kind of thing that you get
with artificial limbs that you connect
it and then people learn to operate the
artificial limb you know really
impressively quickly at least from from
what I hear so and we have a system that
is ready to learn the world's reaction
at the risk of going into way too
mysterious of land what do you think it
takes to build a system like that
obviously we're very far from
understanding how the brain works but
how difficult is it to build this mind
of ours you know I mean I think that
yonder Coons answer that we don't know
how many mountains there are I think
that's a very good answer I think that
you know if you if you look at what cool
Ray Kurzweil is saying that strikes me
as of the war but but I think people are
much more realistic than that were
actually they Mesa sabe is and Yanis and
so the people are actually doing the
work fairly realistic I think - maybe
phrase it another way from a perspective
not of building it but from
understanding it how complicated are
human beings in the following sense you
know I work with autonomous vehicles and
pedestrians so we tried to model
pedestrians how difficult is it to model
a human being their perception of the
world the two systems they operate under
sufficiently to be able to predict
whether the pedestrians gonna cross the
road or not I'm you know I'm fairly
optimistic about that actually because
what we're talking about is a huge
amount of information that every vehicle
has and that feeds into one system into
one gigantic system and so anything that
any vehicle learns becomes part of what
the whole system knows
and with a sister multiplier like that
there is a lot that you can do so human
beings are very complicated but and and
you know system is going to make
mistakes but human makes mistakes I
think that they'll be able to I think
they are able to anticipate pedestrians
otherwise a lot would happen they're
able to you know they're able to get
into a roundabout and into the end to
traffic so they must know both to expect
though to anticipate how people will
react when they're sneaking in and
there's a lot of learning that's
involved in that currently the
pedestrians are treated as things that
cannot be hid and not treated as agents
with whom you interact in a game
theoretic way so I mean it's not it's a
totally open problem and every time
somebody tries to solve it it seems to
be harder than we think and nobody's
really tried to seriously solve the
problem of that dance because I'm not
sure if you've thought about the problem
of pedestrians but you're really putting
your life in the hands of the driver you
know there is a dance as part of the
dance
that would be quite complicated but for
example when I cross the street and
there is vehicle approaching I look the
driver in the eye and I think many
people do that
and you know that's a signal that that
I'm sending and I would be sending that
machine to an autonomous vehicle and it
had better understand it because it
means I'm crossing so and there's
another thing you do that actually so
I'll tell you what you do because we
watch I've watched hundreds of hours of
video on this is when you step in the
street you do that before you step on
the street and when you step in the
street you actually look awake away yeah
yeah now what what is it what the saying
is mean you're trusting that the car who
hasn't slowed down yet will slow down
and you're telling him yeah I'm
committed yeah I mean this is like in a
game of chicken so I'm committed and if
I'm committed I'm looking away so there
is you you just have to stop so the
question is whether a machine that
observes that needs to understand
mortality here I'm not sure that it's
got to understand so much it's got to
anticipate so and here but you know
you're surprising me because here I
would think that maybe you can
anticipate without understanding because
I think this is clearly what's happening
in playing go or in playing trace
there's a lot of anticipation and there
is zero understanding so I thought that
you didn't need a model of the human yes
and the model of the human mind to avoid
hitting pedestrians but you are
suggesting that I do yeah you do as and
then it's then it's a lot harder so this
is all and I have a follow-up question
to see where your intuition lies is it
seems that almost every robot human
collaboration system is a lot harder
than people realize so do you think it's
possible for robots and humans to
collaborate successfully if we talked a
little bit about semi autonomous
vehicles like in the Tesla autopilot but
just in tasks in general if you think we
talked about current you'll know where
it's being kind of system one do you
think those same systems can borrow
humans for system to type tasks and
collaborate successfully well I think
that in any system where humans and the
Machine interact that the human will be
superfluous within a fairly short time
and that is if the Machine has advanced
enough so that it can really help the
human then it may not need the human for
a long
now it would be very interesting if if
there are problems that for some reason
the machine doesn't you're not so but
that people could solve then you would
have to build into the machine and
ability to recognize that it is in that
kind of problematic situation and and to
call the human that that cannot be easy
without understanding that is its it
must be very difficult to to program a
recognition that you are in a
problematic situation without
understanding the problem but that's
very true in order to understand the
full scope of situations that are
problematic you almost need to be smart
enough to solve all those problems it's
not clear to me how much the machine
will need the human I think the example
of chess is very instructive I mean
there was a time at which Kasparov was
saying that human machine combinations
will beat everybody even stockfish
doesn't need people yeah and alpha zero
certainly doesn't need people the
question is just like you said how many
problems are like chess and how many
problems are the ones where are not like
chess where even well every problem
probably in the end is like chess the
question is how long is that transition
period I mean you know that that's a
question I would ask you in terms of men
autonomous vehicle just driving is
probably a lot more complicated than go
to solve that yes and that's surprising
because it's open no I mean you know I
couldn't that's not surprising to me
because the because that there is a
hierarchical aspect to this which is
recognizing a situation and then within
the situation bringing bringing up the
relevant knowledge and and for that
hierarchical type of system to work you
need a more complicated system
currently a lot of people think because
as human beings this is probably the the
cognitive biases they think of driving
is pretty simple because they think of
their own experience this is actually a
big problem for aai researchers or
people thinking about AI because they
evaluate how hard a particular problem
is based on very limited knowledge but
basically how hard it is for them to do
the task yeah and then they take for
granted I mean maybe you can speak to
that because most people tell me driving
is trivial and and humans in fact are
terrible at driving is what people tell
me and I see humans and humans are
actually incredible at driving and
driving is really terribly difficult
yeah so is that just another element of
the effects that you've described in
your work on the psychology side oh no I
mean I haven't really you know I I would
say that my research has contributed
nothing to understanding the ecology
into understanding the structure of
situations yeah and the complexity of
problems so all all we know is very
clear that that go it's endlessly
complicated but it's very constrained so
and in the real world there are far
fewer constraints and and many more
potential surprises so so that's
obviously because it's not always
obvious to people right so when you
think about well I mean you know people
thought that reasoning was hard and
perceiving was easy but you know they
quickly learned that actually modeling
vision was tremendously complicated and
modelling even proving theorems was
relatively straightforward to push back
in and out a little bit on the quickly
part they haven't it took several
decades to learn that and most people
still haven't learned that I mean our
intuition of course AI researchers
have but you drift a little bit outside
the specific a I feel the intuition is
still perceptible yes all no I mean
that's true I mean intuitions the
intuitions of the public haven't changed
radically and they are there as you said
they're evaluating the complexity of
problems by how difficult it is for them
to solve the problems and that's got
very little to do with the complexities
of solving them in AI how do you think
from the perspective of AI researcher do
we deal with the intuitions of the
public so in trying to think me arguably
the combination of hype investment and
the public intuition is what led to the
AI winters I'm sure that same can be
applied to tech or that the intuition of
the public leads to media hype these two
companies investing in the tech and then
the text doesn't make the company's
money and then there's a crash is there
a way to educate people is there to
fight the let's call it system 1
thinking in general no I think that's
the simple answer and it's going to take
a long time before the understanding of
where those systems can do becomes you
know button becomes public knowledge I
and and then and the expectations you
know there are several aspects that are
going to be very complicated that the
the fact that you have a device that
cannot explain itself is a major major
difficulty and and we're already seeing
that I mean this is this is really
something that is happening so it's
happening in the judicial system so you
have
you have system that are clearly better
at predicting parole violations then
than judges but but they can't explain
their reasoning and so people don't want
to trust them we are seem to you in
system one even use cues to make
judgments about our environment so this
explain ability point do you think
humans can explain stuff no but so I
mean there is a very interesting aspect
of that humans think they can explain
themselves right so when you say
something and I ask you why do you
believe that then reasons will occur to
you and you were but actually my own
belief is that in most cases the reasons
are very little to do with why you
believe what you believe so that the
reasons are a story that that comes to
your mind when you need to explain
yourself
but but but people traffic in those
explanations I mean the human
interaction depends on those shared
fictions and and the stories that people
tell themselves you just made me
actually realize and we'll talk about
stories in a second that not to be
cynical about it but perhaps there's a
whole movement of people trying to do
explainable AI and really we don't
necessarily need to explain hey I just
need to explain itself it just needs to
tell a convincing story yeah it doesn't
missus the story doesn't necessarily
need to reflect the truth is it just
needs to be convincing there's something
you can say exactly the same thing in a
way that's sound cynical abysm sounds in
a grave and so but but the objective
brilliant of having an explanation is is
to tell a story that would be acceptable
to people and and
and for it to be acceptable and to be a
robustly acceptable it has to have some
elements of truth but but the objective
is for people to accept it it's quite
brilliant actually but so on the and the
stories that we tell sorry to ask me to
ask you the question that most people
know the answer to but you talk about
two cells in terms of how life has lived
the experience self and remembering self
and you describe the distinction between
the two well sure I mean the there is an
aspect of of life that occasionally you
know most of the time we just live and
web experiences and they're better and
they are worse and it goes on over time
and mostly we forget everything happens
we forget most of what happens then
occasionally you when something ends or
different points you evaluate the past
and you form a memory and the memory is
schematic it's not that you can roll a
film of an interaction you construct in
effect the elements of a story about it
about an episode so there is the
experience and there is a story that is
created about the experience and that's
what I call the remember II so I had the
image of two selves so there is a self
that lives and there is a self that
evaluates life now the paradox and the
deep paradox in that is that we have one
system or one self that does the living
but the other system the remembering
self is all we get to keep and basically
decision-making and and everything that
we do is governed by our memories not by
what actually happened it's it's
governed by by the story that we told
ourselves or by the story that we're
keeping so that that's the distinction I
mean there's a lot of
ideas about the pursuit of happiness
that come out of that what are the
properties of happiness which emerge
from yourself there are there are
properties of how we construct stories
that are really important so that I
studied a few but but a couple are
really very striking and one is that in
stories time doesn't matter there's a
sequence of events so there are
highlight those not and and how long it
took you know they lived happily ever
after
and three years later something it time
really doesn't matter and in stories
events matter but time doesn't that that
leads to a very interesting set of
problems because time is all we got to
live I mean you know time is the
currency of life and yet time is not
represented basically in evaluative
memories so that that creates a lot of
paradoxes that I've thought about yeah
they're fascinating but if you were to
[Music]
give advice on how one lives a happy
life
well this and such properties what's the
optimal you know I give up I abandoned
happiness research because I couldn't
solve that problem I couldn't I couldn't
see and in the first place it's very
clear that if you do talk in terms of
those two selves then that what makes
the remembering self happy and what
makes the experiencing self happy are
different things and I I asked the
question of suppose you're planning a
vacation and you're just told that at
the end of the vacation you'll get an
amnesic drugs who remember nothing and
they'll also destroy your your photos so
there'll be nothing would you still go
to the same vacation
and and it's it turns out we go to
vacations in large part to construct
memories not to have experiences but to
construct memories and it turns out that
the vacation that you would want for
yourself if you knew you would not
remember is probably not the same
vacation that you will want for yourself
if you will remember so I have no
solution to these problems but clearly
those are big issues and you've thought
about issues you've talked about sort of
how many minutes or hours you spend
about the vacation it's an interesting
way to think about it because that's how
you really experience the vacation
outside the being in it but there's also
a modern I don't know if you think about
this or interact with it there's a
modern way to magnify the remembering
self which is by posting an Instagram on
Twitter on social networks a lot of
people live life for the picture that
you take that you post somewhere and now
thousands of people sharing and
potentially petitioning millions and
then you can relive it even much more
than just those minutes do you think
about that i magnification much you know
I'm too old for social networks I you
know I've never seen Instagram so I
cannot really speak intelligently about
those things I'm just too old but it's
interesting to watch the exact times you
describe I make a very big difference I
mean and it will make it will also make
a difference and that I don't know
whether it's clear that in some ways
the devices that serve us supplants
function so you don't have to remember
phone numbers you don't have you really
don't have to know facts I mean the
number of conversations I'm involved
with when somebody says well let's look
it up so it's it's in a way it's made
conversations well it's it means that
it's much less important to know things
you know it used to be very important to
know things this is changing so the
requirements of that that we have for
ourselves and for other people are
changing because of all those supports
and because and I have no idea but
Instagram does connected so well I'll
tell you train you I mean I wish I could
just have the my remembering self could
enjoy this conversation but I'll get to
enjoy it even more by having watched by
watching it and then talking to others
will be about a hundred thousand people
scary's is this to say well listen or
watch this right it changes things
it changes the experience of the world
that you seek out experiences which
could be shared in that way it's in and
I haven't seen it's it's the same
effects that you described and I don't
think the psychology of that
magnification has been described yet
because in your world
the sharing then was appear there was a
time when people read books and you
could assume that your friends had read
the same books that you read so there
was kind of invisible sharing a year it
was a lot of sharing going on and there
was a lot of assumed common knowledge
and you know that was built in I mean it
was obvious that you had read the New
York Times it was obvious that you'd
read the reviews I mean so a lot was
taken for granted that was shared
and you know when they were when there
were three television channels it was
obvious that you'd seen one of them
probably the same so sharing sharing
he's always been always was always there
it was just different at the risk of
inviting mockery from you let me say
there that I'm also a fan of Sartre and
Camus and existentialist philosophers
and I'm joking of course about mockery
but from the perspective of the two
selves what do you think of the
existentialist philosophy of life so
trying to really emphasize the
experiencing self as the proper way to
or the best way to live life I don't
know enough philosophy to and so that
but it's not a you know the emphasis on
an experience is also the emphasis in
Buddhism right it's so that you just
have got to to experience things and and
and not to evaluate and not to pass
judgment and not to score not to keep
score so if when you look at the the
grand picture of experience you think
there's something to that that one one
of the ways to achieve contentment and
maybe even happiness is letting go of
any of the things any of the procedures
of the remembering self well yeah I mean
I think you know if one could imagine a
life in which people don't score
themselves it it feels as if that would
be a better life as if the self scoring
and you know how am i doing a kind of
question is not is not a very happy
thing to have but I got out of that
field because I couldn't solve that and
and that was because my intuition was
that the experiencing self that's
reality but then it turns out that what
people want for themselves
there's not experience that they want
memories and they want a good story
about their life and so you cannot have
a theory of happiness that doesn't
correspond to what people want for
themselves and when I when I realized
that this this was where things were
going I really sort of left the field of
research do you think there's something
instructive about this emphasis of
reliving memories in building AI systems
so currently artificial intelligence
systems are more like experiencing self
in that they react to the environment
there's some pattern formation like
learning so on but you really don't
construct memories except in
reinforcement learning everyone swather
you replay over and over yeah but you
know that would in principle would not
be you know yes useful do you think it's
a feature a bug of human beings that we
that we look back oh I think that's
definitely a feature that's not a bug I
mean you you have to look back in order
to look forward so without without
looking back you couldn't you couldn't
really intelligently look forward you're
looking for the echoes of the same kind
of experience in order to predict what
the future holds yeah though Viktor
Frankl in his book man's search for
meaning I'm not sure if you've read
describes his experience at the
consecration a concentration camps
during World War two as a way to
describe that finding identifying a
purpose in life a positive purpose in
life can say one from suffering first of
all do you connect with the philosophy
they he describes they're not really I
mean the so I can I can really see that
somebody who has that feeling of
per person meaning and so on that that
could sustain you I in general don't
have that feeling and I'm pretty sure
that if I were in a concentration camp
and give up and die you know so he talks
he is he's a survivor yeah and you know
he survived with that and I'm and I'm
not sure how I central to survival the
same years yeah I do know when I think
about myself that I would have given up
at oh yeah this isn't going anywhere and
there is there is a sort of character
that that that manages to survive in
conditions like that and then because
they survive they tell stories and it
sounds as if they survived because of
what they were doing we have no idea
they survived because the kind of people
that they are and the other kind of
people survives them to tell them such
stories of a particular guy so I'm not
so that you don't think seeking purpose
is a significant driver and are the
units it's a very interesting question
because when you ask people whether it's
very important to add meaning in their
life that's oh yes that's the most
important thing but when you ask people
what kind of a day did you have and and
you know what were the experiences that
you remember you don't get much meaning
you get social experiences then and and
some people say that for example in in
in child you know in taking care of
children the fact that they're your
children and you're taking care of them
makes a very big difference I think
that's entirely true but it's more
because the story that we are telling
ourselves which is a very different
story when we're taking care of our
children or when we're taking here other
thing jumping around a little bit in
doing a lot of experiments let me ask a
question
most of the work I do for example is in
the wall in the real world but most of
the clean good-sized that you can do is
in the lab so that distinction do you
think we can understand the fundamentals
of human behavior through controlled
experiments in the lab if we talk about
pupil diameter for example it's much
easier to do when you can control
lighting conditions yeah thanks
so when we look at driving lighting
variation destroys yeah absolutely your
ability to use pupil diameter but in the
lab for as I mentioned semi autonomous
autonomous vehicles in driving
simulators we can't we don't capture
true honest human behavior in that
particular domain so your what's your
intuition how much of human behavior can
we study in this controlled environment
of the lab a lot but you'd have to
verify it you know that you'll your
conclusions are basically limited to the
situation to the experimental situation
then you have to jump the big inductive
leap to the real world so and and that's
the Flair that's where the difference I
think between the good psychologist and
others of the mediocre is in the sense
of that your experiment captures
something that's important and something
that's real and others are just running
experiments so what is that like the
birth of an idea to his development in
your mind to something that leads to an
experiment is that similar to maybe like
what I Steiner good physicists do is
your intuition you basically use your
intuition to build up but I mean you
know it's it's very skilled intuition
right I mean I just had that experience
actually I had an idea that's turned out
to be very good idea
a couple of days ago and and you and you
have a sense of that building up so I'm
working with a collaborator and he
essentially was saying you know what
what are you doing what's what's going
on and I was I really I couldn't exactly
explain it but I knew this is going
somewhere but you know I've been around
that game for a very long time and so I
can you you develop that anticipation
that yes this this is worth following
now that he's here that's part of the
skill is that something you can reduce
two words in describing a process in in
the form of advice to others know follow
your heart essentially you know it's
it's like trying to explain what it's
like to drive it's not you've got to
break it apart and it's not and then you
lose and then you lose the experience
them you mentioned collaboration you've
written about your collaboration with
Amos Tversky that this is you writing
the twelve or thirteen years in which
most of our work was joint four years of
interpersonal and intellectual bliss
everything was interesting almost
everything was funny
and that was a current joy of seeing an
idea take shape so many times in those
years we shared the magical experience
of one of us saying something which the
other one would understand more deeply
than a speaker had done contrary to the
old laws of information theory it was
common for us to find that more
information was received than had been
sent
I have almost never had the experience
with anyone else if you have not had it
you don't know how marvelous
collaboration can be so let me ask a
bird perhaps a silly question how does
one find in create such a collaboration
that may be asking like how does one
find love but yeah yeah to be you have
to be lucky and and I think you have to
have the character for that because I've
had many collaborate
I mean none worth as exciting as with
almost be but Fahad and I'm having it
was very so it's a skill I think I'm
good at it
not everybody is good at it and then
it's the luck of finding people who are
also good at it is there advice in a
forum for a young scientist who also
seeks to violate this law of information
dairy
I really think it's so much luck is
involved and you know in in those really
serious collaborations at least in my
experience are a very personal
experience and and I have to like the
person I'm working with otherwise you
know I mean there is that kind of
collaboration which is like an exchange
a commercial exchange of giving this you
give me that but the the real ones are
interpersonal they're between people
like each other and and who like making
each other think and who like the way
that the other person responds to your
thoughts you have to be lucky yeah I
mean but I already noticed if I even
just me showing up here evil you've
quickly started to digging in a
particular problem I'm working on and
already new information started to
emerge is that a process you just the
process of curiosity of talking to
people about problems and seeing I'm
curious about anything to do with AI and
robotics and on so and I knew that you
were dealing with that so it was curious
just follow your curiosity jumping
around and a psychology front the
dramatic sounding terminology of
replication crisis but really just the
at times this this effect at a time
studies do not are not fully
generalizable they don't you have being
polite is it so I'm actually not fully
familiar well the memory how bad it is
right so what do you think is the source
where do you think I think I know what's
going on actually I mean I have a theory
about what's going on and what's going
on is that there is first of all a very
important distinction between two types
of experiments
and one type is within subject so it's
the same person has two experimental
conditions and the other type is between
subjects where some people have this
condition are the people in that
condition they're different world and
between subject experiments are much
harder to predict and much harder to
anticipate and the reason and they're
also more expensive because you need
more people and it's just so between
subject experiments is where the problem
is it's not so much and within subject
experiments it's really between and
there is a very good reason why the
intuitions of researchers about between
subject experiments are wrong and that's
because when you are a researcher you're
in a within subject situation and it is
you are imagining the two conditions and
you see the causality and you feel it
and but in the between subjects
condition they don't like they see they
live in one condition and the other one
is just nowhere
so our intuitions are very weak about
between subject experiments and that I
think is something that people haven't
realized and and in addition because of
that we have no idea about the power of
manipulations of experimental
manipulations because the same
manipulation it's much more powerful
when when you are in the two conditions
then when you live in only one condition
and so the experimenters have very poor
intuitions about between subject
experiments and and there is something
else which is very important I think
which is that almost all psychological
hypotheses are true that is in the sense
that you know directionally if you have
a hypothesis that
a really causes B that that it's not
true that is causes the opposite of B
maybe a just and very little effect but
hypotheses are true
mostly except mostly they're very weak
they're much weaker than you think when
you are having images of so the reason
I'm excited about that is that I
recently heard about some some friends
of mine who they essentially funded 53
studies of behavioral change by 20
different teams of people with a very
precise objective of changing the number
of time that people go to the gym but
you know and and the success rate was
zero the knocks one of the 53 studies
work now what's interesting about that
is those are the best people in the
field and they have no idea what's going
on so they are not calibrated they think
that it's going to be powerful because
they can imagine it but actually it's
just weak because the and you are
focusing on on your manipulation and it
feels powerful to you there's a thing
that I've written about that's called
the focusing illusion that is that when
you think about something it looks very
important more important than it really
is more important than it really is but
if you don't see that effect the 53
studies doesn't I mean you just report
that so what was I guess the solution to
that
well I mean the the solution is for
people to trust their intuitions less
all to try out their intuitions before I
mean experiments have to be
pre-registered and by the time you run
an experiment you have to be committed
to it and you have to run the experiment
seriously enough
and in a public and so this is happening
and the interesting thing is what what
happens before and how do people prepare
themselves and how they run pilot
experiments it's going to train the way
psychologies done and it's already
happening
do you ever hope for as my connect to
the this study sample size yeah I do
ever hope for the internet or do you
know this is really happening
MTurk yeah everybody is running
experiments on him to look and and it's
very cheap and very effective do you
think that changes psychology
essentially because you're think you can
object it then truly it will I mean I
you know I can't put my finger on how
exactly but it that's been true in
psychology with whenever an important
new method came in it changes the feel
so and an M torque is really a method
because exact it makes it very much
easier to do something to do some things
is there are undergrad students will ask
me you know how big a neural network
should be for a particular problem so
let me ask you an equivalent equivalent
question how big how many subjects they
study have for it to have a conclusive
result well depends on the strength of
the effect so if you're studying visual
perception the perception of color many
other are the classic results in in
visual in color perception we've done on
three or four people and I think and one
of them was called a blind but or they'd
partly colorblind but on vision you know
you belong many people don't need a lot
of replications for some type of
neurological experiment neuro
when you're studying weaker phenomena
and especially when you're studying them
between subjects then you need a lot
more subjects than people have been
running and that is that's one of the
things that are happening in psychology
now is that the power is a statistical
power the experiment is increasing
rapidly does that between subjects as
the number of subjects goes to infinity
approach well I mean you know goes to
infinity is exaggerated but people the
standard number of subjects for an
experiment psychology with 30 or 40 and
for a weak effect that's simply not
enough and you may need a couple of
hundred I mean it's that that sort of
order of magnitude what are the major
disagreements in theories and effects
that you've observed throughout your
career
that's the stand today well you work on
several fields yeah but what still is
out there as major disagreement offs in
your mind and I've had one extreme
experience of you know controversy with
somebody who really doesn't like the
work that they must risky and I did and
he's been after us for 30 years or more
at least when I talk about it well I
mean his name is good Giga answer he's a
well-known German psychologist and
that's the one controversy I have which
I it's been unpleasant and no I don't
particularly want to talk about it but
it's there is their open questions even
in your own mind every once in a while
you know we talked about semi autonomous
vehicles in my own mind I see what the
data says but I also constantly torn do
you have things where you or your
studies have found something but you're
also intellectually torn about what it
means and there's been maybe
disagreement
you within your own mind about
particularly I mean it's you know one of
the things that are interesting is how
difficult it is for people to change
their mind essentially you know once
they're committed people just don't
change their mind about anything that
matters and that is surprisingly but
it's true about scientists so the
controversy that I described in other
it's been going on like thirty years and
it's never going to be resolved and you
build a system and you live within that
system and other other systems of ideas
look foreign to you and there is very
little contact and very little mutual
influence that happens a fair amount
do you ever hopeful advice or message on
that we think about science thinking
about politics thinking about things
that have impact on this world how can
we change your mind I think that I mean
on things that matter or a political or
a little religious and people just don't
don't change their mind and by and large
and there is very little that you can do
about it the what does happen is that if
leaders change their mind so for example
the public the American public doesn't
really believe in climate change doesn't
take it very seriously but if some
religious leaders decided this is a
major threat to humanity
that would have a big effect so that we
we have the opinions that we have not
because we know why we have them but
because we trust some people and we
don't trust other people and so it's
much less about evidence than it is
about stories so the way one way to
change your mind isn't at the individual
level is that the leaders of the
communities you look up with the stories
change
and therefore your mind changes with
them so there's a guy named Alan Turing
came up with a touring test yeah
what what do you think is a good test of
intelligence perhaps we're drifting in a
topic that were maybe philosophizing
about but what do you think is a good
test for intelligence for an artificial
intelligence system well the standard
definition of you know official general
intelligence is that it can do anything
that people can do and it can do them
better yes what what we are seeing is
that in many domains you have
domain-specific and you know devices or
programs or software and they beat
people easily in specified way but we
are very far from is either generally
ability a general-purpose intelligence
so we in in machine learning people are
approaching something more general I
mean for alpha 0 ISM was much more
general than than alphago and but it's
still extraordinarily narrow and
specific in what it can do so we're
quite far from from something that can
in every domain think like a human
except better what aspects of the Turing
test has been criticized its natural
language conversation you know that it's
too simplistic guys it's easy to quote
unquote pass under under constraints
specified it what aspect of conversation
would impress you if you heard it is it
humor is it what what would impress the
heck out of you if if you saw it in
conversation yeah I mean suddenly wit
would yeah which would be impressive and
and humor would be more impressive than
just factual conversation which i think
is is easy and illusions would be
interesting and metaphors would be
interesting I mean but new metaphors not
practice metaphors so there's a lot that
you know would be sort of impressive and
that it's completely natural in
conversation but that you really
wouldn't expect there's the possibility
of creating and a human level
intelligence or super human level
intelligence system excite you scare you
well I mean how does it make you feel I
find the whole thing fascinating
absolutely fascinating exciting I think
and exciting it's also terrifying you
know but but I'm not going to be around
to see it and so I'm curious about what
is happening now but I also know that
that predictions about it are silly we
really have no idea but it will look
like 30 years from now
no idea speaking of silly bordering and
the profound they may ask the question
of in your view what is the meaning of
it all the meaning of life
he's a descendant of great apes that we
are why what drives us as a civilization
as a human being as a force behind
everything that you've observed and
studied is there any answer or is it all
just a beautiful mess there is no answer
that that I can understand and I'm not
and I'm not actively looking for one do
you think an answer exists no there is
no answer that we can understand I'm not
qualified to speak about what we cannot
understand but there is I know that we
cannot understand reality you know
and I mean there's other thing that we
can do I mean you know gravity waves and
that's a big moment for Humanity and
when you imagine that eeep you know
being able to to go back to the Big Bang
that's that but but the y-yeah the
warrior than us
the why is hopeless really day thank you
so much it was an honor thank you for
speaking thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation and thank you to our
presenting sponsor cash app downloaded
use code Lex podcast you'll get ten
dollars and ten dollars will go to first
a stem education nonprofit that inspires
hundreds of thousands of young minds to
become future leaders and innovators if
you enjoy this podcast subscribe on
YouTube get five stars an apple podcast
follow on Spotify supported on patreon
or simply connect with me on Twitter and
now let me leave you with some words of
wisdom from Danielle Cartman
intelligence is not only the ability to
reason it is also the ability to find
relevant material and memory and to
deploy attention when needed thank you
for listening and hope to see you next
time
you